he loved life local leaders say wadia is
an innocent bystander of hate connected
to the whenever anyone suggests that
Israel is willfully killing civilians
that is the most ignorant bigoted
anti-semitic bull ever he has been an
agent of death and destruction calling
for it cannot be a ceasefire anyone who
calls for a ceasefire is a terrorist
sympathizer under these circumstances
you applauding it well you know I think
you're going to see a new playbook and I
think a lot of Palestinians are going to
get killed came out and found her
6-year-old son while DEA alaume wounded
beyond belief this young boy was stabbed
26 times a tough story to report on
tonight he attempted to choke her and
said you Muslims Must Die 71-year-old
Joseph Shuba now facing first degree
murder attempted first-degree murder and
two counts of hate crime charges 12 in
knife was still in his body when he was
taken for an autopsy somebody was
radicalized somebody did the
radicalizing Israel kills enough of
these sons of [__] it's unaccept
cable it's
disgusting think Israel shutting off
water power and food to Gaza is insane
it doesn't make
sense like what's the end goal there
exactly this guy right here this guy's
trying to build a DA cent in our country
I'm not talking to you right now you're
a c you're trying to build a dawa Center
here Islam is violent by Nature myam
brothers and sisters this is exactly why
we need the dean Center because we have
over 300 million Americans who know
nothing about Islam like this guy you
want to have a talk yeah this guy's
trying to build a DA Center in our
country Sur n is the most violent
chapter of the Quran the dean Center
will be a source of light a mega dawa
Center an educational center helping our
brothers and sisters and Humanity truly
understand Islam and Muslims and
brothers and sisters remember the great
rewards of just guiding one person in
humanity to the truth is better than
everything in this D so get in on all
the rewards and blessings click the link
below donate right now may God Almighty
Allah reward all of
[Music]
you alhamdulillah greetings of Peace we
have some very heartbreaking news police
say the boy and his mother had been
targeted because they're Muslim an act
of hatred against this Palestinian
family this is one of the last pictures
taken of wadia alumi who just a couple
of weeks ago celebrated his sixth
birthday his life was brutally taken
away yesterday morning at his home in
unincorporated planfield after he was
stabbed 26 times with a military style
knife Will County investigators saying
today he and his mother were attacked by
their landlord Joseph chuba the
71-year-old is now charged with
first-degree murder attempted
first-degree murder and two counts of
committing a hate crime what we have is
a murdered Palestinian Child by someone
who is radicalized
by the environment in which we live
right now that casts Palestinians as
human animals just developed I'm here
with I'm at rehab here in the
studio I love you you're do when I was
ready to talk about it I would only talk
to you I was explaining how much respect
I have for the faith of
Islam to the
theum we um just came from the press
conference we we often um see these
things now that are
developing on the other side of the the
world and you wouldn't think now you
know you are um on your way to see me
and then you tell me that right here in
our
backyard we had uh tell it fill us in
what happened yeah this interview was
pre-planned and we were supposed to have
it earlier today but we had to delay it
because of of this incident and you were
there at the press conference and and
you saw and heard sadly um you know our
worst nightmare uh came to fruition a a
warning to our viewers the details ahead
are indeed disturbing um you're right we
live in an interconnected World in all
the um the good and bad ways and what
happens in some places affect what
happens in
others a hate crime a horrible heus
attack on a six-year-old boy and his
mother by their landlord knocked on the
door the mother opened the door he
knocked down the door and that he
attempted to choke her and said you
Muslims must die he attempted to choke
her and he stabbed her and he yelled
things like uh you Muslims need to die
she ran into the bathroom to to call 911
and by the time she was out he had
located her six-year-old son stabbed him
26 times the 12in knife was still in his
body when he was taken for an autopsy
and she says in the texts to her husband
from the hospital hospital where she
sits in serious condition this all
happened in
seconds you know we're uh we're at a
loss of words mhm when you have
something like this happen in our
backyard here in in planfield in the
Neighborville District what is lauded as
one of the safest and best neighborhoods
to raise a family in the United States
not just the safest place to raise a uh
family huh yeah and this wasn't you know
an arbitrary crime this was this was a
crime of of of hate um a hate crime and
somebody was radicalized somebody did
the radicalizing Israel kills enough of
these sons of [__] that this is not a
problem this person wasn't always like
this according to the family as a matter
of fact the family says he was rather
decent with them he said help build a uh
Treehouse that police say he the suspect
built for the victim no warning signs
you've never had any bad interactions
with your neighbor no would Jo know the
father says who doesn't live with a
family cuz the parents are divorced is
just the mother who's 32 and the son who
six that the father said that he had
built the son a um you know a treehouse
in the backyard and he would get him
toys and he was generally nice to them
so when he knocked on the door they they
didn't suspect much he'd been angry
about what's going on in the news and
you've been watching a lot of the news
which takes me to the context of this
and I got to say before I go there that
ultimately the hand that stabs is is the
hand that's to blame right we as a
Muslim Community uh don't like to extend
blame to to the entire Community when a
Muslim acts up so that's pretty clear
but the context in which this person who
otherwise seemed normal became became so
such a monster you know was brainwashed
that context is something for us to
pause and think about the context of the
one-sided lopsided statements by
politicians elected officials by the you
know one-sided coverage by the media day
in day out that built up such a frenzy
of hatred by otherizing Muslims
Palestinians dehumanizing Palestinians
even as Palestinians in Gaza are being
decimated what does the situation on the
ground look like
now well I am standing in sha Hospital
which is located in Dar balah in
southern Gaza and this is where
basically the Israeli military asked
gazin to evacuate and what we are
witnessing right now is whole families
children women arriving to the
hospitals the Israeli wo ples attacked
air striked a home that belonged to Abu
family located in Dar bah in southern uh
Gaza we s whole families I myself so
children at least 10 children under the
age of five with their heads cut off uh
their
buddies
uh if you can see around me we can still
see the ambulances arriving to the um
sha Hospital mostly women mostly
children I mean this is undescribable
this is like a massacre from the
skies you're talking about almost
probably now more than double the number
of victims in the Saturday attack in
Israel happening in Gaza sanctioned This
Time by The World by the United States
by our president by our governor by our
mayor by our elected officials by our
media the same exact voices that
expressed rightly such you know um rage
about targeting innocent civilians in
Israel the those same voices are now
supporting what is happening
they're saying I stand with Israel and
that to me is a clear message of support
as to what Israel is doing to the
Palestinians so you're talking about
2250 civilians civilians killed in Gaza
and more we're still counting 725 at
least of whom are children hospitals
being um attacked even as the entire
Gaza Strip only has 2500 beds in all of
its hospitals and we're talking about
tens of thousands of people injured Ed
bodies strewn on the floor in the
kitchens and the bathrooms those
jam-packed hospitals as these
defenseless people attempt to you know
bring life to these bodies they're being
bombed a million individuals civilians
being asked being demanded commanded to
leave their homes from the north of Gaza
to the South that's an exodus that's a a
stampede that's a recipe for
humanitarian crisis and these are not
just my words but that's also the
assessment of the United Nations
given 24 hours to do so or
else these are the conditions we're
talking about all of this in the already
ravaged you know uh open air prison that
is Gaza completely sealed off Food Water
Shelter food water um uh fuel um
electricity and it's hunting season you
know he shooting you know fish in a
barrel they're sitting ducks so this is
happening and then on top of it those
Palestinians Americans living here you
know heartbroken wored sick for their
family frustrated by this Injustice and
by the double standards are subjected to
acts like this and you can just imagine
where they are mentally right now where
their hearts are where their feelings
are and this father he said two things
to me that were very powerful the first
he said I said you know keep your faith
strong Allah's will is supreme and your
son is an angel he's in Paradise
and he said me and my children all of
us can be sacrificed for
Palestine and the second thing he
said he said I came here for my children
and he started to tear up he's been
strong he's been steadfast he's broken
right he's he's in shock you know he's
completely destroyed inside but is is
putting up his best face but at that
moment you know his voice cracked I came
here for my children
and now I'm burying them and this is his
only child the 6-year-old they just
celebrated his birthday a couple of
weeks
ago and this beautiful little boy this
darling boy wadia let's call him by his
name he loved basketball he loved soccer
he Lov coloring bright colors he left to
swing around he asked his father what
does he love and he looked at me and he
laughed in pain and said he's a
six-year-old boy he loves everything he
loves
everyone he doesn't understand what's
happening in the world but this
radicalized man and what he did to him
and his mother has now brought so much
pain that will never leave the mother or
the father or the extended Community the
family for the rest of their
lives well I want people to really paint
that picture in their mind I mean so
this is they were living there for two
years and she's now at
home and this is the landlord so it's
not some Nut Job off the street uh it's
a house not a apartment building so it's
not just some you know Fringe um person
that you just don't know it's your
landlord and you've developed some kind
of relationship but then you can see how
powerful the what we call this hate
propaganda this atrocity propaganda the
likes of Ben Shapiro person who does not
value life or children or decency the
same way that you do he's been
absolutely ridiculous it's been horrible
Israel kills enough of these sons of
[__] that this is not a problem
whenever anyone suggests that Israel is
willfully killing civilians that is the
most ignorant bigoted anti-semitic bull
ever he has been an agent of death and
destruction calling for it cannot be a
ceasefire anyone who calls for a
ceasefire is a terrorist sympathizer
under these circumstances you applauding
it they say that I want America to fight
Wars for Israel nope nope first of all
Israel can take care of
herself if Israel is forced to the wall
the possibility of nuclear exchange is
extremely high that is why it is very
important that the United States provide
the material Aid to Israel yeah get the
out of the country this is Jewish
country only we don't need
Muslims in God's name I don't know how
you can watch someone like that and not
feel like you know and and categorizing
you know human beings as animals
now so this this person if he's watching
someone like Ben Shapiro if he's
listening to Jord Peter give him hell
give him them hell so what happens now
this gets into your blood your mind your
psyche and you're seeing and then the
whole not to talk about you have the um
the CNN you have a Sarah uh Sidner yeah
CNN's journalist uh apologizes for
making claims of Palestinian beheaded
children do you care about the babies
that were beheaded the babies they were
never beheaded that was a madeup story
how do you know not true it's show me
the pictures now so what about show me
the pict you're a l full you're full of
the reporting by uh one Israeli TV
channel that 40 babers were murdered by
Hamas including being beheaded uh makes
a number of the front pages we have
asked on three occasions uh the IDF to
confirm they have not confirmed this
reporting if you don't read the
newspaper you're uninformed if you do
read it you're misinformed I was a CI
director we lied we cheated we steal
stole like well that that went viral and
in started with a soldier who's known
for his right-wing Tendencies who spoke
to a journalist who's apparently known
for being incompetent cuz she was MH and
then it just became a story and nobody
verified it and it got all to the
president and the president repeated it
he repeated it and by the time they
corrected it and retracted it the damage
was done now obviously it's not to say
that other forms of targeting civilians
is okay I mean what happened in Israel
is something you know I don't condone I
don't as a Muslim condone I don't care
where you stand on the conflict Etc as a
Muslim I'm pretty clear you don't Target
civilians it's not something I would
ever condone as even for a just cause
but I thought we all agreed on that I
thought both sides agreed on that but
the same side that agreed with me that
this is atrocious when it happened in
Israel suddenly turned around and
applauded it accepted it and on top of
it cheered for it on top of it became
material support for it gave $8 billion
gave our biggest frate our biggest
warship for it and and gave every piece
of moral support every statement you can
give that I stand with this is what
they're telling us and that's very
confusing to me because I'm supposed to
be the terrorist sympathizer do you
think now this all this that we're
talking about and then the lie that's
spread all across the globe babies
beheaded this man is seeing that he's
getting pumped up now he's got a
Palestinian
tenant does that's part of it but it's
not this one story it's you know the
whole atmosphere the atmosphere the
story that failed to distinguish
between actors of a crime and people
Rank and file families and moreover
giving their blessing to the
decimation of these hundreds of
thousands of people from the
skies dehumanizing them as human animals
per the verbatim language of the Israeli
defense minister nobody chided him for
that nobody you know approached him with
with any words of criticism for using
these racist inhumane terms but that set
the ground for how a lot of the media
and the politicians in America thanks to
the political pressures in this country
they've sold their souls they've showed
cowardly immoral
leadership and they've just piled on and
so someone like that person some
weak-minded weak-- sold person becomes
radicalized becomes brainwashed and acts
upon it they've turned neighbor on
neighbor this is somebody who built a
treehouse now he's somebody who's
stabbing his tenants to death choker
said you Muslims must die and we have to
pause and ask what is the power of media
what is the power of this one-sided you
know uh volume this this this this
onslaught of of of material that breeds
and fans the Flames of hate I'm I'm I'm
just trying to wrap my mind around it it
just all this that's uh we've seen this
before Eddie haven't we we've seen this
both 911 you would think that we learned
from this and we haven't learned a thing
we're back to square one we're back to
square one it seems like huh because the
moment we're under pressure we fall back
to that stupid Stampede style and it's
not mindless actually it's mindful they
know what they're
doing they know that there's another
side to the story they know that
Palestinians suffered for 75 years they
know that what Hamas did does not
represent Palestinian history
Palestinian life you know the the
Grievances the the absolutely legitimate
grievances Palestinians have cannot be
summarized and shut down in this little
capsule that they call Hamas and then
they left to harp on that because that
takes away from the larger story and the
larger context and all the suffering and
all the abuse and all the dispossession
the occupation itself which is the root
cause of this conflict and the
oppression the apide regime that comes
along with it nobody wants to talk about
that instead they want to extend Hamas
to the entire Palestinian population if
not the entire Muslim
population and breed fear and hatred and
scare Monger against all Palestinians
Arabs and Muslims and so they can
justify their war crimes and so they can
have a cover for the immoral you know
death and destruction that they're
wreaking on Regular People mhm so it's
not that people can understand when they
cut off the uh food the water the
electricity you have 2 What two
million people human beings so they know
now they know they're violating uh human
rights agencies organizations are
stepping up uh war crimes are being
committed targeted attacks on civilian
infrastructure with a clear aim to cut
off men women children of water
electricity and heating with the winter
coming these are acts of pure Terror and
we have to call it as such colle
Collective punishment Collective
punishment but it's not it's not that
people can't identify that the the human
rights they understand the human rights
but they have a problem distinguishing
who's human it seems like it's just a
double standard I mean we understand
that these acts a wrong when it's the
right
victim if it's Israelis if it's
ukrainians if it's so so that's the game
okay they're human but they're are anals
in Europe if it's if it's a if it's a
white population but somehow when it
comes to brown and black quite frankly
we don't seem to to get it all of a
sudden we get confused and we can still
see in front of our very own eyes the
same images of Destruction right
targeting civilians hospitals schools
neighborhoods but suddenly we don't have
the same response we don't have the same
morality and suddenly we're excusing it
and we're saying oh but they they use
these civilians as human Shields his
head got in the way of my
bullet yeah you've heard probably most
of these talking points it seems like
they got a a memo and just everyone is
repeating the same talking points I call
it a stampede a stampede of Madness of
immorality of hypocrisy of hate a
stampede just like the wilder beast
mindless you know talk about human
animals
it's human
animalistic to Fan the Flames of hate
and to excuse the murder of civilians at
this level there's a lot of uh
Christians also are starting to wake up
to this and call other Christians who
have gone towards the Zionism and
calling them away from this but I'm also
just shocked because you see you know
our friends and others who are out there
uh many conservative Christians who now
have fallen into this trap and they're
going down this direction and you have
Jesus who we love is one of the
mightiest Messengers obviously we love
Jesus peace be upon him he was just a
prophet in signific no no no we don't
even believe he was a prophet what do
you think he was what do you guys I mean
I what I what do I think he was
historically I think he was a Jew who
tried to lead a revolt against the
Romans and got killed for his trouble
just like a lot of other Jews at that
time who were crucified for trying to
lead revolts against the Roman and got
killed for their trouble he's and he's
the prince of priest and we prach this
love love your neighbor this that the
other but it seems like and I was
listening to this um Palestinian
Christian and he was like talking
against the Zionism and and the
Christians he's just really disappointed
how they said how they've pretty much
forgotten about them the Christians
there that's a missing part of the of
the story again all these human stories
are missing because they only want to
talk about Hamas because when they only
talk about Hamas they're able to render
Palestinians as Orcs right as as sort of
you know there's just an extension of a
militant group that kills and you've
heard this term that they call them not
Orcs huh I mean that's the description I
would use as to how they're this a rabbi
actually I was listening to one of the
on the extreme side was actually oh he
did actually use that term so I didn't
even know that I just want to say this
to our Christian friends you know uh
just to just to call it as it is and say
it straight out you know you guys are
worshiping one
Jew that's a mistake you should be
worshiping every single one of us
because we all die for your sins every
single day and that's exactly what's
going on here where we're all God's
first B we're dying for your sins right
now because because the Jewish people in
the land of Israel are the B work
against the
Orcs okay the Orcs are coming not to a
theater near you but to your home I'll
actually I actually didn't know that
yeah but that's how they're trying to
present Palestinians and so you listen
you have to justify mass murder somehow
so to do it you need to
dehumanize those you are trying to to
wipe out so that nobody can come after
you and say that you are a mass killer
that you are engaging in state Terror
you have to justify your act and so you
have to build up the hatred you have to
build up the
dehumanization and that's why they only
want to talk about one word but they
don't want to talk about the actual life
that is Palestinian life the weddings
the graduations the dinner parties the
families the shopkeepers the everyday
life that doesn't
exist all all of that doesn't exist it's
just it's just a bunch of militants and
an outgrowth
that is the Palestinians to it mind you
this whole conflict began in 1947 1948
years before Hamas was ever formed Hamas
is a consequence to the creation of
Israel among many other
consequences and
so to start history at that point and
the conflict at that point and then also
to start it last Saturday not to be able
to contextualize larger issue this is
not to excuse the act as I said earlier
when we're referring to this landlord
Those who commit a crime by their hand
they are to
blame but how can we talk about the
larger conflict if we only have the
memory of Saturday we don't have the
memory of the air raides before that the
murder of many IFI if murdering
civilians is the issue which I think it
is then how come there was no concern
how come there was no outrage when 30 40
times the number of civilians that were
were killed in Israel were killed in
Palestine over the last few years
happened through air rates through
settler violence and and it's not just
about murder it's about the humiliation
and the dispossession taking land taking
homes forcing people out at will
impunity nowhere for you to go Gaza
Itself by the way that these two million
these are not natives to Gaza these are
already displaced people whose lands
have already been confiscated whose
possessions have already been taken
who've been forced into Gaza a lot of
them and now they're being forced into
Southern Gaza and from there God knows
where maybe they'll push them into Egypt
or out into Jordan and so on and so
forth that is part of the story now they
can ignore that all the all day long but
the world knows the context and how can
you bring peace if you can't even
acknowledge reality if there's no
accountability right so what we're
seeing right now is is a clown show
frankly it's it's delusional and it's
double you know there's it's duplicitous
there's a double standard I'm all for
having clear moral standards when it
comes to not targeting civilians but I
would want the other side those who are
pro-israel to show that they actually
stand for that I don't think that they
do I want to share a couple Clips with
you what can the people that are not
familiar with how IDF operates learn
meaning allegedly they sent 3,000 texts
to um Palestinian citizens urging them
to leave they've dropped leaflets
they've dropped food before they do
what's called I believe roof knocks
that's saying hey you've got five
minutes to vacate the building cuz we've
identified this building as a place that
a missile came from so meaning they're
trying to limit civilian casualties uh
whereas obviously Hamas is will will
gladly rape and pillage whoever they
come across what should the world know
about how the IDF is operating to save
civilian
lives well you know I think you're going
to see a new playbook and I think a lot
of Palestinians are going to get killed
there's nowhere to
go I mean this is what they call
gaslighting right gaslighting this is
gaslighting I mean this is this is
insane propaganda I mean imagine if I
were to tell you hey Eddie you and your
family you got 5 minutes to get out of
here I warned
you and then I wreak havoc on your house
now imagine if I say this about your
neighborhood imagine imagine if I say
this about your City imagine if I say
this about your entire country I mean
you're talking about a million people
that's half the population leaving so
half the population has homes in which
missiles are being launched from is it
is not about that and this whole
so-called benevolent IDF is part of that
ridiculous propaganda I mean the IDF is
created to Gun Down Palestinians to take
over
land we have a right to defend
themselves they say but do you have you
have a right to occupy do you have a
right to attack do you have a right to
raid do you have a right to kill
civilians that seems to be what they
believe is part of self-defense so now
we have a problem as to the definition
of
self-defense and when you move the
goalpost that way it becomes a semantic
exercise it becomes a game and that's
what we're seeing and there are a bunch
of those tropes a bunch of those canards
a bunch of those excuses
you hear oh you know they use when
whenever the numbers come out and they
can't dispute them of how many people
die and how innocent they are because
they're children and women if they were
men they would just attribute them being
you know militants yes so okay let's
talk about the children and the women
and then what did he do then they go to
the point that oh well we were just
shooting the militants but they used the
children women as human Shields you
always hear this yes you always hear
this how do you respond to that I mean
is that what you did when you were
attacked in Israel
were these dead Israeli women and
children human
Shields what gives you the right or the
thought that you're human enough to want
your women and children to
live but that Palestinians are so
subhuman that they want their children
and women to die to protect themselves
these men at the very root of this
regardless if it's Hamas or whoever
right the very notion and this and this
is something that they address to the
entire Palestinian popul to the
Palestinian makeup right it's it's meant
to dehumanize Palestinians that they're
less than you and me that they don't
have normal familial relation
relationships they don't have normal
human instincts they're Human
animals and they do it as they raise
their country their land to the ground
if you can call it a country I mean this
strip is essentially an open air prison
it's it's it's called a strip for a
reason many call it now a a
concentration camp that's pretty much
what it is and they've tried Palestinian
people God bless their hearts are res
are resilient people and I can't imagine
what life is like in a place like this
you know most densely populated um
sealed from all sides they get to decide
what goes in what comes out whether it's
a pencil or or a medicine and despite of
that they've lived and they've they've
married and they've had weddings and
they've had birthday parties and they've
had soccer games and they've had
homework and they've had school
so they try to live and that's that's a
testament to Palestinian resilience but
they want to erase Palestinian life and
that's why I tell my Palestinian
brothers and sisters especially the
young people who are involved in
activism is drop the slogans right the
hey the hoos you know the
chants and fight back with what matters
your
stories if the idea here if if if the
strategy here is to dehumanize you so
that they can erase you and why wipe you
out then you had better humanize you you
had better tell your story the story of
your cousin of your nephew of your aunt
of your uncle who is back home what
they're going through put a face to the
story and tell the stories of your past
not just your present your
grandparents your parents and what
they've been through and how they've
felt we can't erase the human when it
comes to the pal inian side when it
comes to understanding or covering the
Palestinian side but that's what the
media has done consistently that's
definitely what the Israeli government
and its um modus operandi when it comes
to its communication and propaganda has
done that is what the United States in
in lock step with Israel has done that's
what this horrible man who killed this
you know innocent child has fallen for
and so the way to fight back is
existence is resistance exist with your
story what do you like to say when
people go uh they say okay this was when
they go historically and then you you
hear um them using this argument now
that this is our land this is the Jewish
land this is from 3,000 years ago and
now this is our Birthright how do you
like to answer this you know I am not
interested in these types of debates and
conversations because what you're going
to have is one side whatever you tell
them is going to have some answer for
that it's going to have some alternative
view of what you're saying and vice
versa these debates go nowhere what
we're talking about right now is not
some academic debate what we're talking
about right now is human rights abuse
that's what we've been talking about
that's what's been happening what we're
talking about is humanitarian crisis
what we're talking about is war
crimes and in instances the civilians
are Target acts of Terror whether it is
you know by militants or by governments
and their
militaries and so that's what interests
me in terms of we have to we have to
have that tough conversation and we have
to level and say look you can't get away
with this you have to be accountable for
this those who say I stand with Israel
have to own this that's you telling me
this it's not me you say I stand with
Israel so you say I stand with war
crimes you're telling me you stand with
oppression and occupation you're telling
me you stand with rais in hospitals to
the ground in neighborhoods killing of
women and children the stats are there
the numbers are there the stories are
there you're telling me you stand with
that I don't tell you I stand with
terrorism I've never told you that you
accuse me of that I've never said I
stand with that but you say you stand
with Israel so you stand with what
Israel does yeah and and you have you
see Israeli Jewish you have um people I
I recently saw an Israeli Jewish man
he's crying it's unacceptable it's
disgusting I've seen videos
you
know I saw videos of Palestinian dads
holding their his dead like 5-year-old
daughter I
mean and and there was another one that
like as a father it's even hard to talk
about this dude was holding his infant
it was like a year
old
and he was like patting her on the back
and saying like his final goodbye I mean
it was he's holding her like she's alive
like he's just burping her or
something
I didn't expect to get emotional about
that but like I'm a new dad and that
[__] really [__] me
up and I hate to see
it it's not right I think people in
Israel that support the government and
the government need to watch that
[__] think Israel shutting off water
power and food to Gaza is insane it
doesn't make
sense like what's the end goal there
exactly this is a cruelty and a
brutality that is
unbelievable and Joe Biden talks about
the other side the Palestinians as being
evil this is such hypocrisy it is
enraging this this this hypocrisy these
attempts to show the other side as evil
while completely glossing off the
savagery by Israel and with the support
like you said earlier support of the
United States look at these pictures
what do you think is under this Rubble
this is all civilian it's always
civilians 55% of the people in guys are
are under the age of 18 it's an entire
Society of children but if you're a
human being like a human being right
hang with me for one second so as soon
as I heard that Israel cut off
palestine's water my first thought was
who the cuts off water to millions of
children and civilians during a time of
War what kind of a barbaric Act is that
and my second thought was wait why the
Israel control palestine's water and a
brief search got me to this by Amnesty
International titled the occupation of
water all right soon after Israel
occupied the West including East
Jerusalem and the Goda strip the Israeli
military authorities Consolidated
complete power over all water resources
and water related infrastructure in the
occupied Palestinian territories opt and
I know what you're thinking well they
took over existing infrastructure to
build some new one Israeli military
order 158 stated that Palestinians could
not construct any new water installation
without first obtaining a permit from
the Israeli Army since then the
extraction of water from any new source
the development of any new water water
water infrastructure would require
permits from Israel which are near
impossible to obtain it gets they are
unable to drill new water wells install
pumps or deep in existing wells in
addition to being denied access to the
Jordan River right Israel even controls
a collection of rainwater throughout
most of the West Bank and rainwater
harvesting systems owned by Palestinian
communities are often destroyed by the
Israeli Army as a result some 180
Palestinian communities and rural areas
in the occupied West Bank have no access
to running water they don't have access
to water bro what theu going on here
because the resulting disparity in
access to water between Israelis and
Palestinians is truly staggering water
consumption by Israelis is at least four
times out of Palestinians living in the
opt Palestinians consume an average of
73 L of water per day per person which
is well below the world health
organizations recommended daily minimum
minimum mother in rural areas it's at
low as 20 lers per person per day and
how much water do Israeli drink sure
I'll Tell You by contrast an average
Israeli consumes approximately 300 L of
water per day you see we talk a lot
about values but let me tell you
something about American values if I
took my dog to a restaurant right now
the server the owner on their own DME we
bring out a cup of water for a strangers
for a strangers [__] this isn't during
war time this is status quo what kind of
an Insidious
F will make it a point to make sure
intentionally that an entire population
stays thirsty people out here talking
about Freedom voting rights passports
airplanes he's watching he's saying look
you know he's it's blowing his mind I
don't know if you saw many of these
video know people who just have a heart
their heart is when they're seeing like
you're saying The Human Side they're not
falling for the these are animals and
they're seeing these they're seeing
actually images now this is not fake
news they're seeing all of the the
hospital footage they're seeing fathers
with their children Fair Point they you
seeing body parts all over the place
look in Israel proper right you have
people who are so incensed Israelis
Jewish Jewish Israelis who are so
incensed with what's happening in their
name
and and they let it be known and some of
them are reporters some of them are are
some newspapers like the
hits um some of them are influencers
some of them are Everyday People they're
a smaller minority that need to go ahead
and yeah they're vifer yes uh definitely
they're not in the majority otherwise
you wouldn't have Nan in power the
majority voted for him at least the
plurality and looking at the general
propaganda in Israel on their television
on their news and under social media uh
definitely these voices are in the
minority but they exist and in the
United States they exist as well I mean
Jews um some of them uh who consider
themselves to be pro-israel some who
don't but you have those voices who are
pretty clear about their condemnation of
the human rights abuses um in the name
of Israel or in general yeah right and I
I was called by a rabbi who who uh we
had you know gone off on the wrong
footing and this guy's a pretty
well-known know leader in the Orthodox
Jewish community and he was pretty
genuine right when he called me and said
look I um there's hurt in my community
but I'm calling to express you know my
empathy with the hurt and yours to ask
how you're doing you know he said I
don't want to debate you know I said the
same thing and he didn't call to Levi a
litmus test right it was a human to
human conversation yeah and we had gone
off to the wrong footing but I had
confronted him about what was the
problem and he had clarified and
apologized and we became something of
friends and so a little later he called
and he said I've been thinking about
what you said about our common humanity
and I've been thinking about the pain in
your community and I appreciated that
that sense of Goodwill that's all we're
asking for here right we're asking for
us to become to be the humans that we
are you know I don't want I don't want
to fall into I don't want us to fall
into tribalism and and and
territorialism and teams Muslims Jews
right this that I think we need to fall
back in our common Humanity draw your
virtues and values from wherever you
want for me it's from Islam
mhm but show me who you are through your
positions through your stances and
moreover through your
actions and you know it's easy to
propagandize it's easy to throw terms
like you know terrorist terrorist
sympathizer terrorist supporter but you
know I've never stood for the murder of
any civilian but I see today in my
country in the United States of America
from my president all the way down to
some shotty influencer like Ben
hero Expressions that support the murder
of civilians or at least excuse them or
at least contextualize them as okay what
do you what do you suggest you know um
how do you tackle because you're seeing
so many videos you're seeing um so many
things coming up and it seems like one
of the one of the things that you're
getting to see is you're getting to see
people's colors you're getting to see
people you know the true self coming out
we don't have a problem if somebody's
doing something against because I think
that's that's another the another
important things why why Islam
is it's authentic you have everything
there from when you wake up in the
morning to when you go to sleep
everything is laid out beautifully so we
can call out someone if they're doing
something opposite to Islam if
somebody's going out there and killing
innocent people we we have clear the
prophet Muhammad he clearly forbade
killing innocent men women and children
it's very crystal clear you can't get
around it so now how about on the other
side you seen you've seen these videos
with where are you from I'm from is are
you IDF Soldier yes I am didn't the IDF
they bombed Gaza and they and they they
killed hundreds of of children I don't
know about it okay I just know that we
bomb them because they bomb us okay and
what about before that why did they bomb
you guys I don't know why okay maybe
something like a lot of years ago but
you you you don't know the information
before Israel 1948 it was Palestine yeah
oh no it's called isra no it it was
called Palestine before 1948 maybe it is
and it still is right now it's occupied
Palestine yes yeah I wish IDF more
children okay and I wish the IDF find
you and okay why
okay isra Palestine and if you talk it
like again I will you in your okay
mother wait does he kill innocent
Palestinians I every pal see so every
Palestinian you see you every see I just
[Music]
some of these um and and you've seen
actually the march of return remember
the march of return you had like 700
there was no human Shields then these
were people in wheelchairs you were uh
these were uh for you had uh journalists
you had um you had uh just your average
person who was there they weren't
putting anybody there was no soldiers
there so they were trying to protest
peacefully and you see I think it was
like8 almost 200 people were were gunned
down
by the IDF but then you're you're seeing
the IDF where are they getting this you
see some rabbis I don't you see these
who are saying show no
mercy anyone who is merciful over
vicious people ultimately will become
vicious towards merciful people there is
no permission from the Torah to have any
Mercy
whatsoever during war not on children
not on women not on
anybody
why because if a person understands what
is War and why you're fighting they're
actually Shing so you're actually in a
time of War you're not supposed to have
you seen some of these videos we of
course I mean you know there's
definitely that component of
radicalization right the religious
radicalization it's out of this world I
hyperal so now our Christian friends and
others who are supporting this shouldn't
they be calling this out if they see
shouldn't they be stepping up like
absolutely because again I mean these
are all gimmicks I mean you know when we
get these calls from people who say do
you condemn this do you condemn that I
said look stop stop it with your gimmick
you tell them just I say stop with your
gimmick you know where I stand because
I've never told you otherwise but you're
telling me you stand with this so you
got to explain yourself mhm okay because
what it is it's a distraction tactic
it's put you on the defensive tactic I'm
supposed to sit on the hot seat and
debate some schmuck like oh Han you know
Hannity or Riley or somebody while they
ask you all these questions and and and
sort of vet your moral character cuz
you're not as moral as he is while this
you know jerk basically is supporting
the murder of children and and women MH
and not apologizing for it beating his
chest proudly saying he stands with it
so no we're not we're not playing this
game yeah my virtues and values are
clear they're consistent I've never said
otherwise and you've told me where you
stand so you need to explain yourself
self That's Where It's At mhm and today
it's again if it were in the reverse I'd
have the same
position if it were the Palestinians
with a massive Army Strong
Army and the Israelis who were you know
cooped up in in some
strip I would have the same exact moral
position it's not about teams it's not
about colors it's not about tribes it's
about Justice truth and the principles
are consistent for me it just so happens
that in this instance we have a clear
occupier and occupied oppressor and
oppressed who happened to be in one side
the Israelis the other side the
Palestinians as it stands today yeah
have you flipped it and ask them and how
was their response you interact with a
lot of different people do you because
obviously the position is clear we
condemn killing of innocent life clear
it's clear we have no problem hesitation
and hesitating in doing this but when
you ask them do you condemn right now
what is it like uh how many babies have
been killed right now 5 600 how many
around that number yeah hundreds I mean
if a journalist has someone to ask you
do you do you ask them uh do you condemn
The Killing now of all these hundreds
hundreds of innocent lives there do you
cond that's where they upis skate
meaning that they try to the human the
human rights violations now with the
shutting off of food the collective
punishment do you condemn the um the
march of return the Christian um Shireen
her name was journalist right who was
journalist assassinated Jour and then
all her her um coffin carriers were
brutalized do you come you can go the
list can go on and on and on they always
what do they say they'll always have an
excuse they they'll always have a
deflection they'll always have a
Counterattack so in the case of what's
happening in Palestine they'll say well
they they brought they brought this upon
themselves at least we're give them
advanced notice how didn't give advanced
notice in
Israel um and um they are they've had
this land for you know whatever number
of years and instead of building it up
they've decided to you know send their
terrorist upon
us and they'll justify and justify and
justify to which I say again we can go
back and debate each point and the
history and the context but I'm just
I'll keep it simple what do you say you
told me you are the one who told me that
there can be no justification
for acts of Terror there can be no
justification for the murder of
civilians and I agree with you I happen
to agree with you but then you you you
reneged on that position and now you're
telling me there is justification
sometimes when it's me doing the killing
for the murder of
civilians when some people and there are
people in the Muslim Community uh in the
Palestinian the Arab Community who will
have a hard time condemning attacks on
on Israel because they feel that they
will lose political capital and that's
what's happening on the Israeli side
they're off fisca on the morality
because they feel they're afraid to lose
political capital and so however um when
when those attacks happened in Israel um
it was clear to me that the Israeli side
was saying you can't ever blame us for
this because there's no justification
regardless of the context regardless of
the occupation regardless of the
oppression this is condemnable period
fine so now are you coming at me and
saying that there is some context some
justification some whatever mitigating
variables for the murder the mass murder
of Palestinians in the Gaza Strip you
see how that double standard Works they
can't when when you are morally
inconsistent you are immoral to be moral
you must have two things Clarity and
consistency the reason they're not clear
is because there's caradus there's no
there's no
courage you need moral courage to be
morally clear and secondly you need to
be consistent in all situations you have
the same standards I'm not seeing that
from many of those who criticize us from
many of those who attack us I'm not
seeing it from politicians from the
media from the Israeli side from the Ben
Shapiro I mean that's a guy who's been
harping on God God God and he said some
very nice things about God and family
for the longest time but his mask has
fallen under the under I'm talking about
now you're getting to see people's True
Colors under the test has been nothing
but an agent of Darkness death and
destruction agent of Darkness you know
he's appealing for it he's raising his
hands up to the skies for it he's
claiming God his God because he's only
his God somehow right um justifies this
and sanctions this and there are
hundreds of people who applaud him for
it and that's scary that's scary and
there ain't no FBI watching that
Facebook group or that Facebook page and
the radicalized voices who are calling
for murder of civilians and applauding
it but you'll have a Muslim or an Arab
or a Palestinian who says something that
isn't remotely as abrasive and maybe
they'll be contacted or called uh before
we conclude tell me this how do you for
the average person I mean now they
understand it seems like the mainstream
media same talking points everything
you're talking about um the the human
story and people if they just put
themselves in the situation of these
human beings how would they react you
have you seen that movie pantri um sorry
suy bred Dawn have you ever seen it a
long time I've heard of it I haven't
watched it this is okay this is my
generation okay a little older than you
but uh I think people should watch that
I mean if you just anybody we're people
of the uh what is the Second Amendment
um uh no
really valuing our land someone steps on
our property what do you think the
average American I mean you see so much
hypocrisy I mean we don't we don't even
we don't get to go so far in the
conversation but if we did that that's a
valid point I we're still we're still at
the point of like if you were compare if
you were just to compare if we put the
American and take them out how would
they handle it if we put the British you
would think like man these pal are very
patient people they are very merciful I
mean you have you have every American
you know in in every red State you know
with a rifle or a gun and an a well
that's not every American but you know a
lot uh you know get off my lawn don't
try on yeah I'm talking about and um
Americans understand that that's that's
a very you know important thing as a
matter of fact this entire country was
built on a reaction to oppression on a
rejection of
Oppression and it was an armed it was an
armed resistance it was an armed uh
Uprising against oppression and and
that's been the case in many instances
of History mhm Western and otherwise
it's only understood and excused as part
of a larger context of push and pull two
sides going at it for different reasons
right but when it comes to other people
it can only be uh you're just evil and
and violent and you're doing it for no
goddamn reason other than to spill blood
now I'm not talking here about targeting
civilians I'm talking about you know
military to military type of of of
warfare or you know struggle um but that
still that kind of that kind of
understanding still wouldn't be given
right it's only given in the context of
say Ukraine yeah but if syrians are
trying to defend themselves against the
same aggressors as it so happens you
know Russian planes then there's not
much support or understanding does it go
back to they look like us they white
like us that's that's part of it that's
part of it part of itra is okay but over
here right and and you're Bosnian Bosnia
wasn't okay Bosnia wasn't okay to defend
themselves
there was an Armistice there was
basically a ban on arms for bosnians at
the same time they were being subjected
to a genocide yeah and it wasn't until
they had been killed Mass murdered in
large numbers that action began to be
taken right and and they're white and
they're European but they were Muslim so
now now we're seeing something of a
theme here so maybe it's the religion
and the race combined um look I don't
like to be flippant right I think at the
end of the day
I judge humans on an individual level
not not not a race level or religion
level but there's definitely a blind
spot in our quote unquote Western
Civilization when it comes to moral
standards their Clarity their
consistency and their applicability to
all people w we that weren't we the ones
here from over here we wanted to uh
prove our point we wanted to win Pearl
Harbor comes and next to you know I mean
this is not um a uh Command Center this
was a whole what was it a whole here
isima nagazaki yeah I mean talk about
justifying you know and again there was
a context for that Etc so you know we're
toggling between anyways we can go down
that road but it's like uh just
hypocrisy upon hypocrisy I mean and you
you you're starting to see people wake
up to a lot of things so just back what
I was saying humanizing the situation
these are not animals um you have the
Nelson mandelas of the world you had the
Jimmy Carter could go to the West Bank
in Gaza or even to East Jerusalem and
see what's happening now to the
Palestinian
that would disagree with my use of the
word apart you had so many people who
actually went down there they sat with
the human to human they saw the
suffering and they concluded that this
is aarth State this is um illegal what
they're doing it's not even debatable I
mean it's only propaganda and and
intentful um delusion I don't think it's
how many human rights organizations have
condemned
this even in Israel there are also human
rights organizations have condemned this
also right others absolutely you know
about yeah that's pretty clear to
everybody how did they get around this
um just pretend it didn't happen uhhuh
just keep repeating the LIE long enough
until a lot of people think it's the
truth yeah and put political pressure
and financial pressure where were
possible mhm and force a singular
narrative and push out and censor other
narrative we're seeing this happening in
America and now if you don't care about
Palestine is if you don't care about you
know whatever is happening in the Middle
East that's that's fine you should still
care about your own civil rights about
your own country's values and ideals you
should still care about for example
freedom of speech and freedom of
expression and for you as a citizen to
not be put in a sheep's position where
your eyes are covered there's wo over
your eyes and you can't see and they
tell you whatever they want you to
believe and you just bleed it out they
should conc you as a free red-blooded
American citizen who says Don't Tread On
Me you know uh but instead we're seeing
a lot of people falling into the minion
position and they're not upset about the
fact that they're s that that America is
censoring information making it hard for
them to understand what's going on in
the world and that our politicians are
basically um plating what they think is
the safer political position it's not
about morality it's not about values
it's about my seat and how I can
maintain it and how I can run for office
again and so it becomes an oligarchy
it doesn't become a democracy okay so
final words what do we say to um our
friends out there they you know recently
before all this kicked off you had many
Christians Jews many people who are
seeing you know what was happening to
our children in the schools the
sexualization of kids our kids alone our
kids alone leave our kids alone our kids
leave our kid alone our alone man walked
into the women's bathroom at McDonald's
I my daughter goes into those bathrooms
and no man needs to be in there you
understand man you are a man you are
created as a man you are a man start
acting like a man [__] we're seeing like
man the Muslims are in the front line
they're like The Last Hope standing you
know against a lot of these things that
are being pushed out there the
destruction of the family and all the
other things they're like man we need to
Ally we need to work together against
all the greater forces that are coming
against
so uh they see they saw what the Muslim
values were they see we worship one and
only one God and now everything's kind
of been derailed we're back to square
what what what would you say to them
what would you say to them who are out
there and you know to awaken this to the
Allies to the non-muslims or to the
Muslims to the to to the the humans out
there to to the non-muslims well well
let me begin with the Muslims I mean to
Muslims I say I say remember your own
values your own standards and don't let
anybody including anybody's Injustice or
evil cause you to re reciprocate or to
lose sense of your standards and values
out of anger out of frustration because
then they win and you lose the real
strength the real win it doesn't matter
if you die right you win still if you
die on your values and standards that's
what our Prophet taught us did you see
did you see just and and this is real
important this is good because we'll
call we will call out our people who are
Muslim are own in the community we will
reprimand them condemn them I don't know
if this AI you can't really trust a lot
of things that are out there you saw
some of these videos and they're using
it against us Muslims acting up maybe
saying some things they shouldn't be
saying you know what I mean whether it's
true or whether it's false I'm not going
to adjudicate I haven't seen those
videos but generally this is the message
I'm giving this is pretty clear that we
have to we have to be a moral people and
we have to have clear stand we have to
let our standards be known and they have
to be consistent and we shouldn't be
afraid or we shouldn't let any political
situation or any situation of duress
cause us to falter on these values okay
steadfast consistent and persistent once
we've done that once we can achieve that
and I think you know a lot of us are
then we can have some ground to stand on
to call others to the same level of
Standards but if you don't have that you
have no like to stand on and I say that
to everybody wherever you are if you're
Jewish you have beautiful you know
teachings MH of of great moral standing
if you're Christian you have the same if
you're most of the world's great faiths
of not all you have something you can
stand on find what that is stand on it
but stand on it with
genuine um self lessness if you worship
God then remember God is in charge not
you there's only two real religions in
the world if I may there is the religion
of God and there's the religion of
ego and we believe as Muslims that
Christianity Judaism Islam the prophets
that came through these movements right
they're all of the same strain they're
all of God right they all preach the
same basic message of God and then you
have humans including those that that
claim to be following these these
prophets and these religions so it's not
these are not two separate domains they
they sort of intersect humans who've
chosen to worship their ego even as they
claim to be men of God or women of God
and so that's the separation for me you
have to check yourself are you
worshiping your ego are you following
your ego your whims and desires as the
Quran calls
it and he says have you seen the one who
follows their whim and desire they
worship that right or do you worship
the object of God and when you do you
can be objective about matters you're
not about tribalism you're not about
territorialism you're not about you know
your own interests you're fair and
you're balanced and you're just God is
just and that's what we aspire to
Justice thank you ahed rehab thank you
so much thank you very much thank you
thank you for uh sheding some light on
this and um thank you guys for tuning in
and we'll see you next time here on the
dean show until then peace be with you
assalam alaykum I have no doubt that it
will be a successful project inshallah
I've had the blessing of knowing brother
Eddie since he started the dean show and
he's one of the most sincere and most
dedicated people to the that I have ever
met so please do support the dean
[Music]
Center I cannot leave without giving you
a gift if you're not yet Muslim and you
tune in in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran on go ahead and visit theen
show.com we'll take care of the postage
and everything and get it delivered to
you and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at 1 1800
662 4752 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaikum